This, my friends,
is a walrus baculum
it's basically a penis bone
found in most placental mammals.
Interestingly, not in humans.
And this is a polar bear
skull, which as you can see
is more streamlined for swimming in the water than a grizzly bear skull.
And over here we have my
giant friend, the rhino head,
which is good for being giant,
for fighting off predators
and fighting for-
I don't know, why do
rhinos have big heads?
And this is the skull
of a pronghorn antelope.
It has these horns that come
off, that are covered in these
keratin sheaths that
fall off once a year.
These are all bones.
Parts of skeletons.
And they're all pretty
freaking awesome.
And I am surrounded by them here
at the Philip L. Wright
Zoological Museum,
at the University of Montana.
And all of these bones have
adapted to help animals survive,
the horns on the pronghorn for
mating displays and self-defense,
the streamlined skull of a polar
bear for swimming in the water,
and the walrus baculum,
for, longevity, I guess.
We're used to thinking of our
skeletons as being the dead parts
of us because that's what's
left over after all of our,
like, stuff that looks
like us has rotted away.
But the fact is, our bones
make up a vital organ system.
And I don't just mean vital
in that, without them you would be
a sort of disgusting
dead pile of lumpy mush,
but also in the traditional
meaning of vital:
meaning it's alive.
It protects your vital organs.
It makes locomotion possible.
It manufactures your blood.
And on top of it all it takes care
of its own repair and maintenance.
Your skeleton is alive people.
And walrus penises are
just the beginning.
So you know what bones are,
but maybe you didn't know
that you don't have to be a
vertebrate or even a chordate
to have a skeleton.
Jellies and worms, for instance,
have hydrostatic skeletons,
made up of fluid-filled
body cavities.
By squeezing muscles around the
cavities, they change their shapes,
and that can be used
to produce movement.
Insects have exoskeletons,of course
made of the nitrogenous
carbohydrate chitin,
and most mollusks have
exoskeletons, too,
in the form of calcium
carbonate shells.
But when it comes to skeletons,
the winningest formula
has been the endoskeleton.
Even though we'd probably feel
a lot safer if we were covered
with armored plates like
some race of Iron Men,
having skeletons inside of
our bodies has allowed us
to grow larger and have much
more freedom of movement.
It's good stuff.
One of the many reasons
you don't see ants
the size of horses
walking around is
well, one, it wouldn't
be able to breathe,
but also, a body with
such a huge volume
would require an exoskeleton
that was exponentially thicker
and therefore heavier and
clumsier, to support it.
So, endoskeletons allow
animals to grow larger
by supporting more mass,
plus, you don't have to worry
about the embarrassment that
comes with unsightly molting!
As adults, humans have 206 bones
of all kinds of shapes and sizes,
including 3 tiny ones in each ear,
1 weird one shaped one like
a horseshoe in your throat,
27 in your hands,
and 26 in each foot.
You also have at least 32 teeth,
unless you play too much hockey,
and even though they're
included in the skeletal system,
they don't count as bones,
because they're made up
of different material,
namely, dentin and enamel,
the hardest material in your body.
And you probably think of
the skull as one big bone,
but it actually consists
of many separate bones,
including 8 plates that cover your
brain and 14 others in your face.
Face bones!
So, simple, right? Well,
you might want to sit down-
You probably already are,
but I'm going to,
because it's time
for Biolo-graphy!
Now, you'd think that we'd
have nailed down the basics
of the human skeleton
a long time ago,
because our teeth and bones
are the biggest, hardest parts
of our bodies, and after
we leave this mortal coil,
they're what stick
around the longest.
It's not like they're super
hard to find and study.
Surely all of those
ancient physicians
who basically invented medical
science would have inventoried
all of our bones pretty
soon after they figured out
that we had bones. Right?
If the answer was yes, do
you think I'd be sitting here?
Must of what we know about
the human skeletal system
is thanks to Andries Van Wesel,
who was born in what's
now Belgium in 1514.
And in those days, if you were
like, a kung fu master of science,
you pretty much got
your own Latin name,
so today he's known
as Andreas Vesalius.
Vesalius came from a long line of
physicians to kings and emperors,
and while studying in Paris,
he began dorking around
in cemeteries and became
interested in what's now known
as osteology, the study of bones.
Perhaps Vesalius' greatest
contribution was showing the world
that everything we thought we
knew about osteology was wrong.
See, back in those days, if you
wanted to become a doctor,
you didn't study bodies or
see patients, you read stuff
written by ancient Romans, whose
work was considered indisputable.
Because, y'know, those guys had
long beards and they wore robes!
But in his research, Vesalius
discovered that Roman texts
about the skeleton,
especially the teachings
of the philosopher-doctor
Galen, were way, way off.
See, Roman law prohibited the
dissection of human bodies,
so none of those guys ever
actually studied human innards.
Instead, they dissected
apes and pigs and donkeys,
and used that to make
assumptions about the human body,
and so for 15 centuries,
young doctors were taught
those assumptions.
But Vesalius revolutionized
osteology, and all of medicine,
by introducing a new practice,
every pre-med student's favorite!
Human dissection!
He instructed students
by dismembering corpses
in front of them and
cataloging their parts,
giving students the
first opportunity ever
to directly observe
the inside of the human body.
These new methods drew
a lot of attention,
particularly from a local judge,
who began donating bodies
of the criminals he
executed to Vesalius.
Suddenly, the dude was up to
his codpiece in pig thieves
and murderers, and by the
time he was 28, he had done
enough research that he published
De humani corporis fabrica.
On the fabric of the human body,
a seven-volume text
on human anatomy,
including the first
comprehensive description
ever made of the human skeleton.
Its beautifully detailed
illustrations are thought
to have been created in the studio
of the Renaissance artist Titian,
featuring pictures of
flayed corpses positioned
in symbolic poses,
and many of the volumes,
some of which still exist today,
are bound in human skin.
So, the takeaway here is that even
though bones are big and hard,
the science behind them
is far from obvious.
Even though we tend to think of
our bones as rigid and fixed,
your skeleton is as dynamic as
any of your other organ systems.
It's built from scratch with
ingredients in your blood,
it's grown according to
glands in your head,
and probably coolest of all,
it's constantly breaking
itself down and rebuilding
itself, over and over again,
for as long as you live.
Most new bone tissue
starts out as cartilage,
which you may know from
your nose and ears.
It's made of specialized
cells called chondrocytes,
and in newly forming bones,
these cells start dividing
like crazy and secrete
collagen and other proteins
to form a cartilage model, or
framework, for the bones to form on
Soon, blood vessels work
their way into the cartilage
and bring plump little
cells called osteoblasts
"oste," which you'll be hearing a lot
of today,
just means bone and
"blast" means germ or bud.
The bone-building that they do is
called, fittingly, ossification.
They first secrete a gelatinous goo
that's a combination of collagen
and a polysaccharide that acts
like a kind of organic glue.
Then they start absorbing minerals
and salts from the blood
in the capillaries all around
them, and unsurprisingly,
they are especially absorbing
calcium and phosphate,
and they begin depositing those
minerals onto the matrix.
With the help of enzymes secreted
by the osteoblasts,
these chemicals bond to
form calcium phosphate,
which crystallizes to
make your bone matrix.
In the end, about two-thirds
of your bone matrix
is proteins like collagen, and the
other third is calcium phosphate.
Kinda surprising, right?
Most of your bone
isn't even mineral,
and even the part that is,
is living tissue.
Because it's all honeycombed
with blood vessels
that allow osteoblasts and other
cells to do their jobs.
Unlike an insect's exoskeleton,
even the hardest parts of
your bones are alive.
Now, even though a bone can
take all kinds of forms,
from big, flat plates
protecting your brain
to the tiny stirrup in your ear,
inside they all tend to have
the same basic structure.
If you cut one in half,
you'd see that the matrix
actually forms in two layers.
The outer layer, called the
compact or cortical bone
is hard and dense and makes up
about 80% of the bone's mass.
In the middle the spongy
or trabecular bone,
is softer and more
porous and contains
the marrow and fatty
tissues in larger bones.
The marrow, of course, makes
not only new red blood cells
but almost all of your
different blood cells
by a process called hematopoeisis.
I'd need like about a
week of your time
and a Greek dictionary to
explain how it does this,
but suffice it to say that
evolution has wisely chosen
the innards of our largest bones
to house the blood stem cells
that together can produce
1 trillion blood cells
in you every day.
That's 10 to the freakin' 12th.
On the outside, the larger
bones of your body
have a similar structure.
Have a look here at this femur,
that's your biggest
bone in your body.
The main shaft is
called the diaphysis,
and each rounded
end is an epiphysis.
When bones grow, as a child grows,
the new tissue forms at the
border between the two,
a place called the
epiphyseal plate.
As they did when they formed
the original bone tissue,
chondrocytes start to
produce new cartilage here,
and the osteoblasts
come in and lay down
more collagen and
calcium phosphate.
So as you grow, the ends of
your bones are actually
growing away from each other
until, by the time you're about 25,
the last of these plates
in your bones hardens.
By the way, this whole
process is stimulated
by growth hormones secreted
from glands all over your body.
But the head honcho right
here is the pituitary gland,
about the size of pea nestled
at the base of your brain.
As adults, this and other glands
produce less growth hormone,
which slows down
our bone lengthening.
But even though lengthening is
a limited-time-only process,
the thickness and strength
of bone must continually
be maintained by the body.
Because, of course,
like all of your cells,
bone cells go through a
lot of wear and tear
and need to be be able to
adjust to changing conditions.
So over the course of each
year of your adult life,
about 10% of your skeleton
is completely broken down,
and then rebuilt from scratch in
a process called bone remodeling.
Here, the main players
are the osteoblasts, again,
and another kind of cell that's
kind of their complete opposite:
osteoclasts, or bone breakers.
You'd think maybe that the
cells that form bone tissue
and the ones that destroy it
would be in some kind of
constant battle in your
body, but during remodeling,
they work closely together and
actually communicate nicely.
It's like, they're
basically frenemies.
Remodeling begins when
osteoclasts are sent,
by way of hormone signals,
through the capillaries
to the sites of microscopic
fractures in the bone matrix.
Once they're in place, they
secrete an acidic cocktail
of hydrogen ions to dissolve the
calcium carbonate into calcium ions
phosphate, water, and other
material that they carry
back to nearby capillaries.
Then they secrete enzymes that
specialize in digesting collagen.
This whole process
is called resorption,
and when the old bone
tissue has been cleaned up,
the osteoclasts send out a hormone
shout-out to the osteoblasts,
who come in and do
their ossification thing.
Bone remodeling is
really pretty amazing,
and it's all ultimately
regulated by hormones
that maintain the levels
of calcium in your blood.
The glands that call the
plays during the bone-breaking
part of remodeling are the
parathyroids in your neck.
When the calcium
in your blood plasma
falls below the
level of homeostasis,
the parathyroid triggers
osteoclasts to
take calcium out of your bones
and release it back into the blood.
Likewise, when blood calcium
levels are too high,
the parathyroid's cousin,
the thyroid gland,
signals osteoblasts to take
calcium out of the blood
and lay it down on the bone
collagen through more ossification.
And remember last week
when we talked about how
the kidneys reabsorb
salts and minerals?
Well, the thyroid also
regulates how much calcium
is reabsorbed in that process,
as well as the amount of vitamin D,
because vitamin D helps
your body absorb calcium
through the small intestine.
And that is why vitamin D is
good for your bones and stuff.
Now, the relation of active
osteoblasts to active osteoclasts
can change dramatically
under different conditions.
The more you stress your bones,
the more osteoclasts work
to break down the bone matrix,
so that it can be re-formed.
Bone stress can include stuff
like fractures, of course,
but it can also be less
traumatic and more sustained:
Exercise causes stress on the
skeleton that helps stimulate
bone remodeling, so when
you're working out,
you're not only building muscle,
you're also building bone.
So, as you can tell, it's
kind of hard to talk
about bones without also
talking about muscles,
and that's what
we're going to do
on the next episode of
Crash Course Biology.
Thank you so much to the Philip
L. Wright Zoological Museum
at the University of Montana.
Sorry, I just hit you.
Check out their tumblr at
UMZoology.tumblr.com. It's awesome!
If you want to review
anything: table of contents!
Just click on it, or just
re-watch the whole episode,
because you know you liked it.
And if you have any
questions for us, of course,
we will be in
the comments below,
as are all of the super
helpful people who are always
answering questions who are not us.
Thank you to those
people by the way.
And we will see you next
time on Crash Course Biology.